I'm I'm from Houston but um I used to
watch your videos back in the States and
I was like walking around I'm like yo I
hear the similar voice I'm like I just
want to come say thank you how are with
you as well yeah how are you come here
don't you you good you from
Afghanistan oh sorry s yeah can you they
waiting for me can you no I just want to
say thank you I got a good question like
I guess just staying on top of the dean
like being able to like pray like I know
I need to pray and like all these things
but like I don't know it's like it's
what advise you with look me personally
yeah when I when I started practicing I
don't remember when I come cuz you know
I had to go through crazy lifestyle you
know I went prison you know it's crazy
lifestyle you know then when
alhamdulillah when I come out prison in
prison I'm strong you know people
praying when I come out prison again you
know you know ATT Temptation you know
money this and that one thing I've
noticed to keep you firm after Allah is
to have good friends around you cuz you
have good friends around you they will
remind you also make sure you pray on
time until the prayer becomes your
nature part of your like not second
nature become your first nature to pray
I'm not the best person to be honest but
when he comes to
prayer something itching me you know
it's not
normal you know doesn't mean I'm the
best person you know but alhamdulillah
because I had to to strive strive so in
you have to struggle you know you know
people talk about Jad this is the
greatest Jihad yeah so that's why I
advise you with make sure you have good
Brothers around you make Dua and
remember we can live this life anytime
bro yeah we can live this life any time
so make sure you pray prayer is very
important very important take this let
me give you as a gift appreciate it man
Allah bless you bro it's nice meeting
you in it's my pleasure to meet you as
well I keep watching you but when I'm
back in the
stone
there